yeah there's like an Afterglow with a
great film where you need time to like
process you you come out of the theater
it's dark but you're still in that world
and you're still in those characters and
it is difficult then to go to another
equally great one or whatever it loses
something because that's the beauty of
loving a film is you're lost in it for
weeks sometimes almost a lifetime if
it's really that powerful yeah I think
what the problem is too is that and I I
said this online and I've I've often
gotten criticism from it
is that
I don't like having an instant reaction
to things
but the way that we as film critics are
and what has kind of been programmed
into our brains is that we want to react
to something as soon as we see it it's
it's what I keep saying about being the
first you want to get into that first
screening you want to be the first to
see the Batman you want to be the first
to see top gun Maverick right there's
something special about being part of
that initial Buzz to kind of be like I
saw this before other people and it's
not anything about ego it's just this
kind of this this feeling of like wow I
was important enough or this studio
looked at me and trust my opinion well
enough that they would include me in
those first batch of reviews of those
first batch of reactions
so I often come out of a movie and
almost subconsciously
first thing I do pull out my phone
and I just start taping reactions I mean
even stuff that's out
like it's just like okay this movie's
been out but I still feel like I have to
chime in on it like when we were at
um a couple of days ago we went to see
minions and I didn't go to the Press
screening for that because it was a busy
week and I wanted to see it at a regular
theater and it was funny because I'm
singing with everyone else and yet as
soon as it's done pull out my phone
reaction it's like there's no need like
all the reviews are out but it's just
like this knee-jerk thing that we all do
because we're we've become programmed
that you want to be part of that buzz
you want to be part of that experience
and that's what social media does I mean
in a lot of ways it's kind of you know
again another controversial tub subject
is
it has taken away from in-depth reviews
I used to be the type of person who
would spend
five hours writing a review and I mean
my wife used to laugh at me all the time
she's like
what do you write a novel over there
like you're talking like 1500 2 000
words every review I I wrote I would go
into like what worked what did and how
it made me feel yada yada yada and it's
so weird because
you put out a tweet and it's like
instant gratification right it's just
like oh oh man he really liked that
that's like oh look look at it look at
all the retwees what are all the likes
and then you post the review like a week
later and you like literally poured five
hours of your time into it it's like 10
retweets 10 likes
and after a while it almost becomes
discouraging you're like why am I going
to spend all this time
pouring my heart and soul sitting down
when I could just have a conversation on
a podcast or on a Twitter spaces
for 15 minutes talk about how I feel and
more people are going to pay attention
to to it that way or even better just
write five tweets and put them in in a
in a thread and there you go and more
people are going to read that and pay
attention to it than anything that I
write in long form
what about when something's embargoed
how do you how do you stop yourself
oh that's
that's really difficult especially when
again it's it's the extremes of
everything right if it's a movie that
you walk out of and you're like it's
fine or you don't really have a reaction
to those are the those are the hardest
ones to review the hardest movies to
talk about
and the ones that have no impact on the
in embargoes because you're just kind of
like all right don't really have much to
say about that anyway but it's when you
see something that's so good or so bad
and I I can tell you this
I have no problem admitting this
I
will tell you that Studios
will
absolutely kill you if you
slander a movie that they have really
really high praise for they're hoping if
they have a really strong box office and
you come out and rip it to shreds when
the Embargo lifts
without going into details I have been
kicked off lists many of times for years
at a time because I said so and so movie
was not good and
it's not just the studios it's it's the
producers it's the directors it's the
Stars they're like did you see what this
person said about our thing and again
social media the lack of control and
everyone's looking for the next click
bait headline
that I have had some tweets of like
something that I felt really strongly
about like in terms of negative
be the headlines of major Publications
as like this movie is the most
disappointing movie that I have seen all
year
and when that gets out and Studio see
that and Talon sees that
not a good not a good look and it's been
really difficult because I always pride
myself on being very very honest
but then sometimes I've also realized
that I'm too honest and I'm kind of kind
of brutally honest to a fault that I've
been sort of trying to find the good
with the bad so I'll try to kind of say
this this and this are pretty good but
this was really bad so it kind of like
Waters down in a little bit so it
doesn't come off as like so harsh and
again
I think that's what any good critic
should do is that they should be able to
look at something and kind of say okay
this movie's really not that good but
there's got to be something good about
it so now I've been more
I don't know take a little bit more time
to process something if I if I have a
immediate like knee-jerk reaction to it
we'll have like negativity that I I want
to process it a little bit and kind of
say okay is there anything about this
that I liked
and kind of make that a little known as
well
and then I'll hammer in on the negative
but I think it's it's really hard
nowadays because this this this this
this area that we live in with criticism
is so vast because before
it was like you worked for a trade or
you worked for a newspaper or TV Outlet
right those were like the three things
and now and I mean this is not new but
like over the past 15 years it's like
you can be a YouTube reviewer you can be
you can have your own blog you can be on
Tick Tock you can be on Instagram you
can be all over you could just do
Twitter you could do letterbox so like
all these voices are kind of coming
together and the studios and they really
do pick people
and it's it's all about relationships
and I I pride myself on trying to have a
good relationship with as many people as
possible but I always promise myself
that I have to be honest I if I don't
like something
I have to I have to be able to say that
I don't like something I get their their
fear of like maybe not being the first
person out of the gate to kind of rip
something to shreds
but to me something that's being lost
nowadays is like this fear of like
losing your access
because you're honest
and I think that's a good point and and
I think it's good to be respected and
not have sort of a used car salesman
Vibe too which I know is prevalent
sometimes in Hollywood but at the same
time I think we've all read reviews
where whoever it is just went for the
jugular on this person and you don't
know did they know them in college like
had is there was there a prior beef and
they just they just attack them on so
many levels so I think there's like this
middle ground but yeah I respect that
that you want to be be honest about the
review and not uh sugar coat it or just
that that's turkey because you want to
be invited back yeah I mean the problem
with criticism nowadays is that
if you're not a voice that agrees with
the masses and and again what are the
masses nowadays right because we live in
our own like bubbles like the industry
film Twitter
Instagram Twitter whatever the heck it
is
all of these things they're very
specific to a very small audience
and you kind of get like obsessed with
it right like and people are on the
internet as we all know are very mean
especially if you voice something that's
different
so I mean I'll give you an example dear
Evan Hansen I like dear Evan Hansen I
like the Broadway musical I like the
movie is it a great movie
no it's it's good
but I'll tell you as one of the voices
to kind of stand up for that movie
the amount of hate you get when you just
kind of disagree with everyone like oh
this has terrible messaging how can you
like something like this and you try to
explain yourself like look at it from
this perspective and like no no no you
don't get it like that's wrong you can't
look at it from that perspective it's
very very difficult to kind of defend
yourself because you're not having a
conversation with with a person you're
having a conversation online with people
who are too afraid to talk to you to
your face
and that's what's also weird about film
criticism is that
a lot of these filmmakers
and actors have now become known to who
I am as a person because I run a critics
organization and because I run a critics
organization I also have to pause a
little bit about my reactions to things
because how does this affect other
members within our organization
so if I don't like something like power
of the dog
how is Netflix going to react when that
movie gets nominated
and we do an award show and we need
those people there
so it kind of has this weird thing that
I start thinking about is like is is
that the reason why most people from
Power the dog didn't come to the award
show because they knew that the person
at the top of the
this organization didn't care for the
movie and then you just kind of have
this weird pause
and I think that that that kind of
trickles down into every aspect of of
filmmaking now is that we see this with
fans right like Sonic right the backlash
of the character design everyone like
backlashed against it and then they
redid the character design granted for
the greater good for that one but Star
Wars Marvel DC it's like there's so much
outpouring of like criticism and Hate
that you almost struggle to kind of like
know where your voice is anymore
because
you want to support these things and you
I I love to Champion creativity and I
always agree with the statement of
artists objective
and I think so many people forget about
it it's like how can you not like this
this movie and it's like just didn't
resonate with me it didn't I didn't like
the characters I didn't like their
Direction I didn't like the story I
didn't like the way it was filmed
there's so many different things that
some person that one person could see
and another person will see something
different and you just kind of have to
learn to live with it so I never I never
take any offense when people really
disagree with me my only thing is when
people start name-calling and like
really start playing you down as like
the worst critic ever because you didn't
like something it's like no it's just
like I didn't see what you saw sorry